i i just have no interest in going to
digital conventions i couldn't think of
a more
boring thing it's it's it's just sad to
me
i get it they've got to keep it they've
got to do it but to me to me it doesn't
it doesn't make me feel happy that
they're doing digital conventions it
just makes me feel sad yeah unless i'm
staying in a
scuffed hotel room that's [ __ ] up from
every all everyone's [ __ ] like just not
the same
yeah it's it's kind of the same as like
virtual
concerts yeah right like like uh
so the fortnite one was pretty cool with
like travis scott did a whole thing for
them that's like a different experience
that's a different experience yeah but
like someone on zoom just dancing in
front of that webcam being like you know
did you see the one that post malone did
for pokemon no no
yeah postmo so like pokemon just
recently announced uh well
uh past the 25th anniversary this year
and post the pokemon the official
pokemon youtube channel
did a virtual concert with post malone
and it is
weird it is weird as [ __ ]
did pokemon reach out to post malone or
was it what
it was like it was like literally like
think of think of like the travis scott
he's like the least
family-friendly kind of image you could
go for that
i expect from nintendo it was this clip
on twitter that went viral
where like one of the lyrics uh to like
post malone's song like obviously you
know like a lot of his songs you know he
swears and writes so they censored it
but i guess they forgot to censor this
one line where he was like
it was just the sex though the sex
though meanwhile there's lugia flying in
the distance
post malone rapping and it was like yeah
so like
they had like the the virtual model of
poshmark
but again it's like in a pokemon way
not even it's like i don't know he was
kind of
halfway between a pokemon model and just
like
a regular 3d model okay and it was
really [ __ ] weird and especially
weird because like
when you think of pokemon and you think
of
modern pop stars yeah post malone is not
the first person you think of
no no right and yet yeah it was really
weird just being like
at the end of the concert he's like
thank you pokemon fans
i love this happened how did i not see
that
i'm surprised you guys didn't see it
it's like kanye west going on the disney
channel or something
all these [ __ ]
you're such a [ __ ] heart i love
it thank you disney like sometimes you
just see
news nowadays and like you can't tell if
it's real news or just a meme anymore
yeah like the real news is the meme
nowadays sometimes
like post malone and pokemon i mean i
like post malone but it was just a
very strange like i don't know if i
enjoyed it it's a very odd comment it's
a very odd combo
especially especially coming from
nintendo as well one of the most was it
yeah yeah yeah i mean it was it was good
like if you're a post malone or a fan
then it was like yeah cool
you're like pokemon i don't know about
like pokemon fans but i mean
i saw it was like pretty positively
received so
i mean good on postmodernism it's kind
of like a pokemon amv to post malone's
music i don't even know
like it wasn't a long concert either it
was maybe about you know like
15 20 minutes maybe so he played you
know he maybe did like three or four so
wait where could you watch this was it
on twitter
it's on the pokemon it's on the official
pokemon youtube channel
like if you look up post malone pokemon
concert it will come up
i just yeah i just don't want to be in
my room attending another this is just
like that's just sad there's just
something about the energy
of having a crowd there that's just that
that you need that energy and it's it's
something that you can't because
nothing's sadder than a virtual mosh pit
yeah yeah oh god that sounds so
depressing yeah oh my god
what's the virtual mosh pit it's just
twitch chat going insane right
that's a virtual mosh pin it's like it's
i love twitch chat and i i love
interacting and i love streaming but
there's something about it when it was
supposed to be live
yeah and like in person when it goes to
twitch it just feels weird or yeah
it's weird i don't really know why and
like conventions i just think are an
experience you inherently just cannot
experience
i mean you go to convention for the
people for the atmosphere otherwise
everyone would be [ __ ] going on their
discord service and talking about anime
being cringy exactly you go to be cringy
in person
yeah meet other cringy people i was like
the whole reason why you go to like
concerts right it's like it's it's of
course to see whoever you're seeing live
but it's also to [ __ ]
see it with people yeah there's
something different about seeing
you know seeing a bland live as opposed
with other people as opposed to
seeing it you know listening to the
album or seeing music videos something
like that there's just
there's just an energy you can't capture
if you're watching it through a screen
exactly
um and i mean that's that's why i get
why people have to do virtual events and
everything but i'm kind of i'm kind of
i've i just want to attend i [ __ ]
miss concerts
i miss crowds yeah and i never thought i
would miss crowds because i hate
questions
i hate crowds so much but like even like
it's not just even being there in a
crowd
or just seeing an event and just hearing
that crowd scream
there's just something special there's
just something that brings that hype to
it yeah like
i get that i get that like um the most
recent like
the most recent event i can think of is
uh league of legends worlds right
normally i'm like super super hyped for
worlds because as you would be for any
other sporting event
but there was just something about
seeing this gameplay
that just didn't have the crowd raw
behind it that just made it feel like
you were just watching a tyler1 stream
or something like that yeah like you're
watching an online tournament
yeah yeah i remember the players they
were saying as well they were like yeah
it's not the same without a crowd yeah
oh yeah of course when you get a win
you know when the crowd's that uh you
know like when someone makes a [ __ ]
amazing play
and you hear that raw there's just
something special about that that
even though i'm not there in person
because i've i've been to you know i've
been there in person and the energy
there is
[ __ ] incredible um but even just
capturing a bit of that energy and
putting it like just hearing that crowd
scream
it's it's it's something that can't be
replicated and
like i know um and i i think it was
china
that tried adding like that that they
tried the cannes laughter effect where
they
they added fake crowds effects yeah yeah
yeah
what to the league of legends yeah yeah
i think so i heard about this this stuff
like someone's probably going to fact
check and call me out on this but i i
think i heard that and that just sounds
i wouldn't be surprised that just sounds
even worse
yeah if they did that just like the
friends [ __ ] like soundtrack starts
playing the science old base just comes